hello
hello
welcome
to five nights at freddy's sister
location
we're going back i've actually been
looking forward to this one um
i've been blasting through them which is
interesting haven't been beating them
i've been doing okay i've been doing all
right but i have not been beating them
also i'm gonna wait until i hear if this
is
too loud or not which i'm not 100 sure
if it will be i think i managed to
balance my audio a little better
slowly but surely i'm becoming a
professional streamer
but alas it cannot last hello hi welcome
some of you may have been expecting this
and to be perfectly honest i have been
too
i'm super excited for this one
i love the music i've already had i
always have loved the sound design and
the music in all these games they all
each have their own unique twist to them
yes we're back we're back once more
thank you so much for joining me here um
but i actually have to restart the game
because
there's an intro screen
that i need to show you and i probably
have to delete the data to be able to
pressing delete
press delete
there's no doubting what you've achieved
on a technical level
these are clearly state-of-the-art
there are just certain design choices
that were made for these robots that we
don't fully understand
we were hoping that you could shed some
light on those
she can dance she can sing she's
equipped with a built-in helium tank for
inflating balloons right at her
fingertips
she can take song requests
she can even dispense ice cream
with all due respect those aren't the
design choices we were curious about mr
afton
[Music]
everyone praise the lord
the lord is back
but we're in the future now or in the
past i don't know i don't know what the
actual timeline of this is i'm sure some
people do but i do not so if for all i
know this is taking place in the year
like 2050 because how else would you get
any kind of animatronic that
good
and also have this weird snake-like
animatronic that is capable of injecting
itself out of a freshly scooped human
and then
using it as like a meat puppet
which i think anybody would find to be a
little bit strange me included you
included all of us included
but what's interesting about this game
is it's kind of one of the first ones
that has a guided narrative to it you
get an actual
kind of
exposure to the world in general that is
five nights at freddy's in its sister
location of course you don't necessarily
know it for sure
but you do get a glimpse into
the deeper understanding of the world
and yes it may in fact be
the bite of 87 but little did we know we
were all assuming that it was in the
1900s
this is actually in the 2000s this is
the bite of 2087.
dun dun dun or 2083 whatever you want to
call it because that's the only time
that this [ __ ] would work
there's no other time really
anyway one of these days i'll watch
matpat's videos
i guess i owe him
for being in in space with markiplier my
upcoming youtube original available for
everyone for free to watch april 4th
link to the trailer in the description
below first day of your exciting new
career whether you were approached at a
job fair read our ad and screws bolts
and hairpins or if this is the result of
a dare we welcome you i will be your
personal guide to help you get started
i'm a model 5 of the handyman's robotics
and unit repair system but you can call
me hand unit your new career promises
challenge intrigue and endless
janitorial opportunities
please enter your name as seen above the
keypad this cannot be changed later so
please be careful
it seems that you had some trouble with
the keypad i see what you were trying to
type and i will auto correct it for you
one moment
welcome eggs benedict
ah good stuff good stuff yeah i remember
when i first came into this i was
actually kind of blown away by this
intro sequence the elevator the moving
pieces the lighting like the flapping
posters all of it
and just the tubes in general the tubes
are here from the get-go like the tubes
are inside us all but the tubes are here
from the get-go
oddly enough i've forgotten everything
that's been happening in this so far i i
really have no idea what's going on you
can now open the elevator using that
bright red and obvious button
let's get to work but i don't know if i
want to
i don't know if i want to all right fine
did anyone ever find if this keypad
actually did anything
[Music]
probably not
probably 100 not
hmm
allow me to fill this somewhat
frightening silence with some
light-hearted banter due to the massive
success and even more so the unfortunate
closing of freddy fazbear's pizza it was
clear that the stage was set no pun
intended for another contender in
children's entertainment unlike most
entertainment venues our robotic
entertainers are rented out for private
parties during the day and it's your job
to get the robots back in proper working
order before the following morning
[Music]
uh-huh i love i just love the door now
the primary control module i've really
actually a crawl space between the two
front showrooms now let's get started
with your daily tasks
view the window to your left this is the
ballora gallery party room and dance
studio encouraging kids to get fit and
enjoy pizza hell yeah let's turn on the
light and see if delora is on stage
let's see press the blue button on the
elevated keypad to your left okay
uh oh it looks like ballora doesn't feel
like dancing let's give her some
motivation press the red button now to
administer a controlled shot i just
absolutely bring it back in her step i
absolutely love just the way that it
presents all of this information to you
so
simply
because i love it because it's dark
humor right
yeah
take that ballora
and then you just like write again yeah
let's check let's see laura are you
there oh wow that's great good job
ballora is feeling like her old self
again and will be ready to perform again
tomorrow
now view the window to your right this
is the fun time auditorium where funtime
foxy encourages kids to play and share
of course try the light let's see what
funtime foxy is up to
that's not friday
looks like funtime foxy is taking the
day off
let's motivate funtime foxy with a
controlled shock
all right you got it three two
[Music]
i guess i gotta do i forgot about
get over here foxy
there we go
looks like funtime foxy is in perfect
working order great job
in front of you is another vent shaft
crawl through it to reach the circus
gallery control module
one second everybody
okay done sorry just
texting some important business to the
people working on in space with
markiplier the link to the trailer of
which is down in the description below
it's almost ready for you to see to
feast your eyes upon in fact it's
exactly exactly two weeks until the show
comes out so why don't you go check it
out the trailer i mean and then the show
when it comes out alright in the vent
i'm going i'm going guys guys
i'm going
i'm going
i love
the actual
circus gallery vent
i'm sorry
i love the actual movement of it because
it like five nights at freddy's 4 which
i just played yesterday really has the
feeling of moving around because
of the glasses the circus babies go all
around let's check the light and see
what baby is up to
i'll go in a sec you go all around in
five nights at freddy's four but this
one actually feels
like it's a location right it feels like
it has space to it there's there's just
like so much more to it it makes it feel
bigger it's one thing to see all these
things from a camera popping up at you
it's another entirely to actually move
through it which is why when the fan
games started doing their free roaming
it just created this whole new dynamic
that just really worked with the
animatronics especially when they were
at the correct scale you know
like nine feet tall lady dimitrescu
height
a little bit shorter than it looks like
a few of the lights are out but we can
fix that later let's encourage baby to
cheer up with a controlled shock uh baby
seems pretty cheerful anyways so uh i
don't know if i need to
[Music]
i'm a zap
let's try another control shot you don't
need to ask me my dude i'm already on it
let's try another controlled shock
well
i wonder if any of these buttons
actually do something because they're
programmed to beep
i don't know if it's just like the whole
space is programmed to beep
but
oh
great job circus baby we knew we could
count on you what that concludes your
duties for your first night on the job
we don't want you to leave overwhelmed
otherwise you might not come back please
leave using the vet behind you and we'll
see you again tomorrow
will you know
i thought i remember something happening
that's a lot of thump-a-lumping over
there
it's echoing whomps in the distance and
i don't like that
huh
okay
i'll go back everything's perfectly fine
oh what was that oh god no
oh my god don't do it
do i die
if i don't move do i die
am i gonna die am i about to am i about
to die is death coming to me
good god
it's fine there's nothing happening no
that it's
no it's it's fine
that's fine it's nothing it's just
circus gallery vent
probably totally fine
ah night one
is it possible to die in night one in
the other games it seems like it
actually is possible to die in almost
all the games
i don't know if there's another day
another dramatic entry in the lives of
vlad and his distressed mistress
where will they go what will they do
all of that and more happening now
clara i tell you the baby isn't mine
can't i tell you that it is
you're the only vampire i've ever loved
and the baby turns his bottles into
powdered milk
that doesn't mean anything
he sleeps on the ceiling fan
upright or upside down why does it
matter you need to be part of your son's
life
i'm an old man clara i can't be your
father
well then at least pay your child
support you deadbeat
will vlad and his distress i forgot
about this i completely forgot about
this next time like my brain is empty of
these videos here for some reason it
just like does not exist in my memory
these interstitials here and i don't
know why
because
hmm welcome back for another night of
intellectual stimulation
career choices and self-reflection on
past mistakes well we're committed to
creating a unique and fulfilling work
experience one part of that commitment
is ensuring that you don't get tired of
the voice that you're hearing right now
using the keypad below please select a
new companion voice for mail press one
for female press two for text only press
three for other options press four
it seems that you had some trouble with
the keypad i see what you were trying to
type and i will auto correct it for you
thank you for choosing
angsty teen
hey angsty teen how you doing god i have
forgotten all this
uh
sorry very important in space with
markiplier things you know the routine
ride the hd
whatever i forgot about if you want
i love
you know the thing about it is i've not
read any of the books but if the books
are written in the same kind of style
that all of this is written in i would
probably love the books i have not even
read a review of the books i have not
even read a break i've not even watched
a video of a breakdown of the books
but there's like something about the dry
dark humor so
funny story uh a dead body was found in
this vent once
okay so not that funny but
it's a story
you're right it is a story that is a
good story how have i forgotten all of
this
this is probably the weirdest revisiting
because everything in this
seems completely new to me
i don't know if i had a memory wipe the
last time i played it but
man it's just it's weird
it's very weird
okay let's start with your nightly
chores uh-huh you should check on
ballora and make sure she's on her stage
but
whatever
whatever okay
hi
huh
i guess ballora has better things to do
let's zap her was that should be fun i
remember looking at this before and i
thought it was like a shadow but was
that ballora standing right outside the
window there is that ballora standing
right outside the window there is a is
that what i'm
is it is
looking at me right now
is malara looking at me right now
you guys can't see because uh my face is
in the way my big beautiful face but uh
that's what you get that's what you get
that's what you get
hello
all right okay then uh
let's check on funtime foxy why not he's
ready for show time tomorrow
oh boy
okay
bye
it is an angsty teen after a while i
forgot there seems to have been a
problem with the voice synthesizer
default settings have been restored
great please proceed through the vent
ahead of you to circus baby's auditorium
great
okay uh i guess i'm done here now
i don't want to go in the vent
great
this is motion trigger circus gallery
vent oh i remember why those voice lines
go off
great
circus baby had a busy day today let's
check the light and make sure she's in
proper working order okay
oh you're not looking at me that's old
circus baby we aren't here to play hide
and seek let's encourage baby to come
out of hiding with a controlled shock
are we sure about that are we sure
oh
let's try another controlled shock
uh-huh oh god there seems to be a power
malfunction that is affecting our
ability to properly motivate baby please
stand by while i reboot the system
i will be offline momentarily during
this process
various other systems may be offline as
well such as security doors vent locks
and oxygen
commencing system restart
great
love
this
motion trigger entryway vent
funtime auditorium maintenance vent
opened
velour gallery maintenance vent opened
[Music]
i don't recognize you
you are new
i remember this
scenario
however
it's a strange thing to want to do to
come here
i'm curious what events would lead a
person to want to spend their nights in
a place like this
maybe curiosity
maybe ignorance
there is a space under the desk someone
before you crafted it into a hiding
place and it worked for him
i recommend that you hurry though
you will be safe there
just try not to make eye contact
it will be over soon
they will lose interest okay
do i go now what happens if i don't
i
i need to know what happens if i don't
go in
i'm gonna die
this is it for me guys this is it
this is great
this is great
you're gonna die
or maybe not
maybe not
zap zips up okay
i guess i'm okay
well it doesn't seem like there's much
to do here so i guess uh hippie to hop
into the what did i just see was that my
reflection in my monitor under the desk
click and drag why what if i don't
what happens if i don't
oh
god
i don't know
it's fine
clicking and dragging
nice
nice
well i'm gonna make some serious eye
contact because i remember baby telling
me
be sure to make eye contact
that's what i remember this is
the
this is like a master class
hi hello i'm looking at you i'm looking
at you hello hello hello hi
hi hey
how are you
good good
you don't know that
oh hi
oh my god
uh-huh
i'm gonna let him open it i'm going to
let him open it i'm going to let him
open it if you don't watch the trailer
i'm going to let him open it if you
don't watch the trailer in the link in
the description i'm going to let him
open it i'm going to let him open it you
better watch the trailer you better go
now you better go now
god
ah
god yeah like i was saying
like i was saying it's just like so well
designed right because you see elements
that play out in the second night that
were there the first night like the the
voice line going with the motion trigger
when you go past it the first time you
hear it you're not sure then you go back
through it and you're like oh that was
obviously me and then when you're in
that far room the second night you know
that something's coming to you because
you were given context clues about that
the previous night earlier in your
playthrough it's all like
super well designed elements to really
build
unease
and then you get this situation where
you've gotten a no one likes a big
eyeball poking out at you no one likes
things looking at you no one likes
being in danger
that's great
this is really great
how about
some eye contact
oh i see you
someone who me your worst
nightmare
hello
hello
hi
hello
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
no
no no
[Music]
okay god just a simple act of
desperately trying to keep your hiding
place safe it's such a simple mechanic
it's such a simple effect
it's just very stressful
huh you'll find a way inside
oh god i was paying attention
no
no
no
[Music]
no
oh
they saw you
they saw you watching them watching the
stream through the stream they knew
they knew because they know it when your
guide comes back online he is going to
tell you that he was unsuccessful
that you must restart the system
manually
he will then tell you to crawl through
ballora gallery as fast as you can to
reach the breaker room oh no if you
follow his instructions
you will die
ballora will not return to her stage
anymore
she will catch you
the power will be restored shortly when
you crawl through ballora gallery
go slowly
she cannot see you and can only listen
for your movement
when you hear her music become louder
she is growing near
listening for you
wait
and be still
thank you for your patience it seems
that the power system cannot be
restarted automatically you will need to
restart the power system manually please
return to the primary control module
okay you got it pal any other eyeballs
still looking at me okay
i guess i'll go then to ballora's
gallery
why i don't know
i don't know i never know these things
i never know
motion trigger great circus gallery
that's me
that's me baby
uh
you will now be required to crawl
through the ballora gallery using the
vent to your left to reach the breaker
room
it is recommended that you stay low to
the ground and reach the other side as
fast as possible as to not disturb
ballora
i will deactivate myself momentarily as
to not create an auditory disturbance
deactivating
thank you
thank you for leaving me to myself
mysterious artificial intelligence
i
remember
hating this
and it's
crazy
there is no
i don't think that there's a deadline
right
so
in honor
of all my favorite speedrunners
i'm gonna go for it
i gotta make it i gotta make it
i'm ready
[Applause]
well that didn't work
i can't imagine why
god i wonder what the speed run of this
game actually is i'm kind of curious i
know there must be some speed runs on it
you will now be required
gallery using the event to your left to
reach the breaker room it is recommended
that you stay low to the ground and
reach the other side as fast as possible
as to not disturb
i will deactivate myself momentarily as
to not create an auditory disturbance
was there anything that was there
anything like shadow bonnie
in this game
or
four
or three
because i don't remember any super
rarities
happening in this one
or at least that i know about maybe it
happened
i just i'm unsure
as to what it would be
i don't know what that is i probably
know what that is okay
so
quick
it seems you are taking a long time
please proceed as quickly and as quietly
as possible
much
[Music]
[ __ ]
right
made it
and that's how you do it
that's how you do it you may now
interface that's how you do it
using the interface
nearby electronics
when you are in danger feel free to
disconnect the interface temporarily
until it is safe to reconnect
huh
oh i forgot
oh
god
everything is okay
everything is okay let's go back to
sleep
i think it was
i forgot that you were here
i forgot that you're exactly right there
okay
oh this
right
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine i'm just gonna go for it what's the
worst that could happen to me
what's the worst that could happen to me
this is what we call speedrun baby
all right
i just love seeing because it's a slight
delay right you know it's like i'm doing
it carefully that i'm like let's go and
then all i see is just hey oh good oh is
that the bite of it no no no
that's really great i'm hoping that the
replay is safe for these streams when
they go
when they go uh now i'm required to oh
no
using the vent
room
it is recommended
reach the other side as fast as possible
as to not disturb ballora
disturbance
deactivating
all right speed run baby
it seems you are taking a long time
please proceed as quickly and as quietly
as possible
uh
bye
okay made it
easy peasy
motion trigger breaker
you may now interface with the breaker
control box you got it using the
interface may disrupt nearby electronics
if you feel you are in danger feel free
to disconnect the interface temporarily
until it is safe to reconnect
go to sleep
why is the danger level not green there
we go
okay here we go
oh my god hi oh my god
go back go back
go back
[Music]
no one is here no one
noah's here
i also love the mechanics of this being
just
you don't really have a time limit it's
just playing with a
relatively simple mechanic
oh my god go
go my friend go
go away
okay we're good
oh god
oh my god oh the flashing lights too
just
but also it's fun that's the thing right
it's
it's like nerve wracking
but also it's fun
right
nope no one is here
let's go
oh
oh
oh oh
i have to play things when he talks
because it's a mascot
response
freddie says something and then the
bon-bon puppet which i don't think i
even understood that before
i just was dumb
and so that's what it is
i see i see
that does it does it right away and then
the danger level is down to nothing
where'd you go
oh my god go
oh my god go away go away please boy
that's what it is
ah that makes so much sense
oh god
he's mad he's mad he's mad he's mad
and he's back
[Music]
okay i guess he does it anyway
oh god no way whoa whoa whoa whoa
he's not saying
much
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm crazy i might
be crazy i might be crazy but it makes
sense it's a response right
great job this completes your tasks for
the night please proceed back through
the ballora gallery with care and we'll
see you back here tomorrow
okay
oh my god
wait i'm getting a i'm getting one of
those headaches with pictures you know
a brain blast
is this a trick
this is a trick isn't it
i could run full sprint through this and
there would be nothing because balor is
not here because they didn't do that
right i remember i'm not even reading
chat i'm not reading i'm going with
confidence because that's how i do i go
with confidence in whatever i do because
this is a trick ballora is
not there and i can run full spread i'm
closing my eyes
and i'm putting my faith in myself
no you can't
no you can't lady
no you can't ballora
easy
easy
see i knew it i remembered
i remembered
i remembered
i remembered because i have a gigantic
brain
my head is huge and my brain is even
bigger
bam told you
you gotta trust me
and you can definitely trust me when i
say you are going to love in space with
markiplier the trailer for which i have
hacked into this game and it's going to
play on the tv right now you're in the
saga of love lost between vlad and his
distressed mistress
can their love rise again
that and more happening now
clara the baby isn't mine
it is glad
they had trouble catching him in the
nursery today
so what lots of kids get hyper and run
around and stuff
they had to knock him out of the air
with a broom
i have to go
they're going to dock your paycheck
they can't do that i'm a vampire i don't
eat paychecks
you work the graveyard shift at the fry
me taco don't lie to me oh the humanity
oh will the heart break in i don't know
these two ships passing in the night
rekindle their long lost love
tune in tomorrow to find out okay
thank you
that's some good popcorn
god i love popcorn
daddy just once let me go play with her
she's so pretty and shiny didn't you
make her just for me
oh that family
ah
back for another day back to another
pivotal night of your thriving new
career where you get to really ask
yourself what am i doing with my life
what would my friend say and most
importantly will i ever see my family
again
we understand the stresses of a new job
and we're here for you to help you reach
a more stable and relaxing frame of mind
we offer several musical selections to
help make this elevator ride as relaxing
and therapeutic as possible we offer
contemporary jazz classical rainforest
ambiance as well as a wide selection of
other choices i
using the keypad below please type the
first few letters of the musical
selection you would prefer
it seems you had some trouble with the
keypad i see what you were trying to
type and i will auto correct it for you
thank you for selecting
casual bongos
now that your elevator experience has
been customized to your needs and you're
thoroughly relaxed it's worth mentioning
that due to your lackluster performance
yesterday your pay has been decreased by
a substantial amount please enjoy the
rest of your descent what about my pay
[Laughter]
i forgot about the casual bongos my god
so many amazing things in this show
show show
in space with markiplier
guys please you should definitely check
out the trailer available through the
link in the description below you won't
regret it
be ready for when the show comes out
on april 4th and it is free i can't tell
you how many people
still don't think it's free
like i don't know if they think it's
like a trick
or if anything like that i literally
have released an entire other show heist
that was also free there are so many
people that watch that trailer and they
leave a comment being like oh is it how
much does it cost
functions from today's shows your
nightly duties will require you to
perform maintenance that you may or may
not be skilled enough to perform
it became necessary for technicians to
attempt to disconnect funtime freddy's
power module however they were
unsuccessful allowing them to try again
would be an inefficient path forward as
we would need to allow six to eight
weeks for recovery and physical therapy
you will need to reach the parts and
service room on the other side of
funtime auditorium to perform the
procedure yourself
let's check on valora first and make
sure she's on her stage i'm sure she is
i'm sure she'd be
god it's like
you
it's
free it's free
oh
great it looks like everything is as it
should be in ballora gallery let's check
on funtime foxy it's important to make
sure she's on her stage before entering
great it looks like everything is as it
should be in funtime auditorium
there is no need to check on baby
tonight please refrain from entering
unauthorized areas proceed directly to
funtime auditorium
oh
well i'm going in
[Music]
hello
[Music]
is me
great
hello
was there a reason for this did you know
that i was on stage once ah
it wasn't for very long huh only one day
what a wonderful day though huh i was in
a small room with balloons and a few
tables
no one sat at the tables though
but children would run in and out
some were afraid of me others enjoyed my
songs
music was always coming from somewhere
else
down a hall
i would always count the children
i'm not sure why
i was always acutely aware of how many
there were in the room with me
two then three then two then three then
four then two
then none
they usually played together in groups
of two or three
i was covered in glitter
i smelled like birthday cake
there were two then three then five then
four
i can do something special
did you know that
i can make ice cream
although i only did it once
there were four then three then two
then one
something happened when there was one
a little girl standing by herself
i was no longer
myself
and i stopped singing
my stomach opened
and there was ice cream
i couldn't move
at least
not until she stepped closer
there was screaming for a moment but
only for a moment
then other children rushed in again but
they couldn't hear her over the sounds
of their own excitement
i still hear her sometimes
why did that happen
you're demon
hell spawn
possessed
evil
does that answer your question great am
i done here how do i say yes why did
that happen yes no i don't know
okay goodbye
goodbye
before she sucks me
turns me into ice cream ice cream
can i have that
that might have been the munch of 83.
i believe that was the glomp of 83.
okay i guess i'm going knock knock hello
poke
unlike ballora funtime foxy is motion
activated for this reason it's important
to keep the room dark as to not
accidentally activate her
you have been provided with a flash
beacon use it if you need to get your
bearings and to ensure you don't bump
into anything
however use it as sparingly as possible
proceed forward to reach the parts and
service room
spam
wow
anybody
i thought i'd be dead by now
maybe if i do this
well
interesting is there anything about the
numbers you know the two then three then
four then five then two
then zero you know all the all those
numbers
it seemed important
it seemed importante
it seemed important
so i'm going to assume that has
something to do with something or other
time
unlike ballora funtime foxy is motion
activated for this reason it's important
to keep the room dark as to not
accidentally activate her
you have been provided with a flash
beacon use it if you need to get your
bearings and to ensure you don't bump
into anything
however use it as sparingly as possible
no proceed forward to reach the parts
and service room
oh
hmm
this is interesting you can kind of hear
some foot shuffling
peekaboo
everyone
pro strats
still there
oh god i thought
i made it huh
parts and service great job reaching
parts and service
it seems that funtime freddy is out of
power which should make your job much
easier sure the release switch for the
chest cavity is located on the underside
of the endoskeleton jaw to reach it we
will first need to open the face plates
you will need to press the face plate
release triggers in a specific order and
it's important to be as precise and as
careful as possible
locate the small button on freddy's face
just under his right cheek and press it
his right cheek
here
great now locate the button under his
left cheek and press it
great now carefully locate and press the
button next to freddy's right eye
he's right
great now carefully locate and press the
button just above freddy's nose
oh god
good job the face plates should now be
open
locate and press the small button on the
underside of freddy's endoskeleton jaw
is it this
is this
excellent the chest cavity should now be
open
remove the power module from the chest
cavity
how
great work you will now be required to
remove the secondary power module from
the bonnie hand puppet
press the large black button beneath
bonnie's bow tie to release the power
module
oh
oh oh
oh god oh god i forgot about this
do i gotta be slow and careful with it
why would you do that
where are you
beneath this bow tie how am i gonna get
that
there was a trick to this press the
large black button beneath bonnie's bow
tie to release the power module there
was a trick to this i remember there
being like a trick
what was the trick
there was a trick
you definitely can't get him when he's
there because his bow
isn't visible there was a trick
oh whoops
oh i ah i remember i remember the trick
i remember it
right
don't you just have to leave your
presence still large black robot to
release the power module
i'm getting to it
yeah it's like you got to let him do his
thing
you gotta sneak up on him because he
slowly emerges
slowly but surely
yeah yeah yeah
oh right because if the map if the mouse
is like over whoa
well i'm dead
god okay hold on
i know i hear the robot you guys are all
just echoing the robot
unlike ballora funtime foxy is motion
activated for this reason it's important
to keep the room dark as to not
accidentally activate her
you have been provided with a flash
beacon use it if you need to get your
bearings and to ensure you don't bump
into anything
however use it as spearing
i think i thought i saw
her whoa i forgot about this
we we oh i accidentally i think i shot
one of them oh wait no
well that's not good
i only have so many cupcakes kids
i'm not gonna be able to get all y'all
hold on
ah perfect
blue oh
all right anyway
so
now
unlike ballora funtime foxy is motion
activated for this reason it's important
to keep the room dark as to not
accidentally activate her
you have been provided with a flash
beacon use it if you need to get your
bearings and to ensure you don't bump
into anything
however use it as sparingly as possible
proceed forward to reach the parts and
service room
was that the disintegration
i don't know why i have to be quiet it's
not like i do
but i feel like it helps me survive
okay there we go thankfully it's not a
very long distance
parts
it seems that fun time freddy is out of
power which should make your job much
easier okay so the release switch for
the chest cavity is located on the
underside of the endoskeleton jaw to
reach it we will first need to open the
face plates you will need to press the
face plate release triggers in a
specific order and it's important to be
as precise and as careful as possible
okay locate the small button on freddy's
face just under his right cheek and
press it okay so
what it is
is
you you put him in the periphery he'll
appear at one of the shoulders right i
can't remember which one
but he does either down there or down
there so you kind of put it here you can
kind of see the peripherals
there
and then you'll
yada yada yada
great now locate the button under his
left cheek and press yeah yeah
great now carefully locate and press the
button next to freddy's right eye
great now carefully locate and press the
button just above freddy's nose
cut me again he got me again good job
the face plates should now be open
locate and press the small button on the
underside of freddy's endoskeleton jaw
excellent the chest cavity should now be
open
remove the power module from the chest
cavity
great work you will now be required to
remove the secondary power module from
the bonnie hand puppet
press the large black button beneath
bonnie's bow tie to release the power
module
do i wait in the center of the chest or
do i
wait waiting one of the sides
i can't remember
oh [ __ ] where did he go
yeah i don't remember which
which side he's supposed to okay so
there he is okay
okay
i'm watching you
oh
damn it
god damn it okay all right
i'll probably get another try yeah here
he goes okay
so he's coming out
press the large black button beneath
bonnie's bow tie to release the
i gotta go slower right i gotta approach
slower that's it right
ah there he goes okay
damn it oh no
he's gonna kill me
oh oh so if i go over the uh his body i
can't go over uh
freddy's body either i gotta go
that's what periphery means
right
oh i still gotta be quick okay i'll be
quick
i'll be quick i'll be lightning fast
watch this watch this watch
this got a great job you've acquired
both power modules this completes your
tasks
let's exit the building through funtime
auditorium and we'll see you back here
again tomorrow
okay
now i do think foxy is here still
foxy's definitely still here
oh god
okay
maybe not
am i crazy
oh god damn it oh
oh wait that was supposed to be it
that's right
that was supposed to be
my brain remembered that it was
definitely there just didn't remember
what that meant
right
right
right
and quiet
right
you've been sleeping for quite a while
thanks very tired working the night
you've noticed that you never left the
building last night
the cameras were searching for you
but they couldn't find you
i have you hidden too well
dang i kidnapped you
great
great
don't be afraid
i'm not going to hurt you
i am only going to keep you for a little
while
try not to wiggle though
you're inside something that came from
my old pizzeria
i don't think it was ever used
at least not the way it was meant to be
used
too dangerous
it's just big enough for one person to
fit inside
but just
barely
you're in the scooping room
do you know why they call it the
scooping room i actually it's beautiful
it's because it's coming
this is the room
i thought
thankfully
i don't think
oh
it sounds like someone else is in the
building
okay bring her over
forward
one
more
okay stop
set it down
watch the step
what happened to it this time it just
seems like these things can't go a day
without breaking down
who knows it's always the same man some
kind of a hardware malfunction
but like i have to be somewhere in 15
minutes and this place gives me the
creeps
let me just get this over with
it's all automated we don't have to be
here for it let's get her on the rollers
and we can go
[Music]
so
hi
you look great
there's something very important that
i've learned how to do over time
do you know what that is
why
how to pretend
do you ever play make believe never
pretend to be one way
when you are really the other never
it's very important
ballora never learns
but i do
they think there is something wrong on
the inside
the only thing that matters
is knowing
how
to
uh-huh
[Music]
you got scooped
i'll open the faceplates for you oh good
that way they can find you on the
cameras oh cool now all you have to do
is wait
i'd recommend that you keep the spring
locks wound up
your breathing and your heartbeat are
causing them to come loose
you don't want them to get too loose
trust me
i'm trying not to i can't quite remember
what else is going to mess with me here
but i'm sure it's a lot
i could just i forgot i could just keep
my uh oh hi oh hi
hi
oh
good
i don't know what's all the way tight
what was i supposed to do about that
i forgot what it was supposed to do
what was i supposed to do about them i
have no idea what i'm supposed to do
about them
[ __ ] oh
right
wiggle i forgot about the wiggling
i'll open the faceplates uh-huh
that way they can find you on the
cameras
now all you have to do okay
these look okay
that's nice i'd recommend that you keep
the spring locks weld up your breathing
and your heartbeat are causing them to
come loose
you don't want them to get too loose
trust me
oh god that one's almost
dead i think they all basically have the
same kind of rotational doohickey
get out of here
oh god oh that was too much wiggle oh
that was way too much wiggle oh i
waggled a little too hard guys
stop go away
okay it's one two three it's a wig
waggle
oh god oh my god
[Music]
oh here comes another
wait did i just see wait wasn't it did
that am i oh god get it no i'm dead i'm
dead dog get out
oh i'm dead
or is it only the ones that climb that
matter it probably is but i am very
close to my demise get off oh my god i'm
dead i'm dead i'm so
dead forgot that they can just climb in
that i think that's what they do but
yeah the ones crawling in i don't need
to worry about the other ones those are
fine whatever you're seeing there
totally fine actually 100
a-okay
all
good with me
oh my god i'm so dead i'm so
incredibly dead
oh my god i'm so dead i'm so incredibly
dead
oh my god they're really going for it
they're really oh god they go red
okay well at least that's an indication
of uh badness oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god i'm so dead on the other
side
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm so dead
i'm dead i'm dead a million ways i'm
dead how dead am i extremely i'm
extremely dead 100
dead
speed run to death
100 death speed run
let's try that again shall we
okay so i
wiggled a little too much
that was the thing i can let them get
all the way to the top i think
so i don't need to waggle them off
too early
because that'll just run me out of time
the beginning phase i need to get them
up as much as possible i have time until
i die
i think that's what it is
who that way they can find you on the
cameras
now all you have to do what are we
looking like is wait that one's okay
i'd recommend that you keep the spring
locks wound up
your breathing and your heartbeat are
causing them to come loose
my breathing in my heart
trust me
yeah best to just get them up one at a
time and not try to spread it out so
much
just because
i need to buy time for when i waggle
here comes one that's fine oh there's
two
is it one or is it three or a two is it
i said a lot of numbers there
which one is it you guys tell me
i think it's just two quick a quick two
a quick back and forth i think that's
all i'll need okay i'm doing okay
it's gonna get worse when they start
piling in
the clown car that is my enclosure
okay i'm doing actually pretty okay i'm
pretty tippy-toppy on this
okay there's two
got him
i gotta try to get two i think
no matter what okay
just quick wubba
i'm doing good okay i got him i got him
i got him the old skills are coming back
i'm pretty much full wound here
i did three accidentally
that was a bit much
it's also about like getting to the next
one with as much precision as you could
possibly allow
because it is just kind of important you
got to just get
[Music]
maximize the amount of time that you are
on these things
some of them go down quick
what is with that
oh god
didn't see that guy almost died there
it's okay it's fine
here comes another they are just piling
in
uh that's not good that's not good i was
doing well
i was
oh yeah yeah
how how how
how
oh that's how
oh
i did it i'm
the best
i survived and you know what reward i
get no it's not the trailer in the link
in the description
there's no link in the description
between
all it is popcorn
and something very special i get
tomorrow
wait was that a vampire joke that was so
lame clara like i haven't heard that a
million times okay well how's this
i'm taking the car the joke's on you
it's a rental
well the joke's on you i set the
thermostat to 90 before i left
good i like it warm
good because i also set the house on
fire how will it all
the passion the tension the intrigue
tune in tomorrow for the exciting
conclusion
all right
i think today is the day i think it is
the day
i think that this is the day
i think today's the day
welcome back to your last day on the job
that is the last day of your first week
some of the most valued qualities that
we like to see in new employees are
determination fearlessness and a genuine
disregard for instinctive
self-preservation
you've earned your one week bonus which
will be given to you in the form of a
delightful gift basket the cost of which
will be taken out of your next paycheck
we have gift baskets containing fruit
nuts flowers and of course the
ever-popular cash basket
using the keypad below please enter the
first few letters of the gift basket you
would like to receive
you know what i'm here for sir
you
i see what you were trying to type and i
will auto correct it for you
thank you for selecting
exotic butters
well i i gotta play that song i gotta
play that song hold on i have to be
aware oh well there are two technicians
on site today try to avoid interfering
with their work if possible also feel
free to ask them why they are still
there and encourage them to go home
uh-huh uh-huh
[Music]
come on
okay all right i gotta go play that song
you guys know the song i'm talking about
the exotic butters uh
like
song if you haven't heard it it's in
like the end of uh
it's the end
that's not it
i gotta find it
well
okay
okay i think this is it
i think this is it
hold the phone
[Music]
no
it
seems you had some trouble oh hold on
okay there we go okay got it
wait is this the right one
thank you for selecting
exotic
butter
sorry i ruined that
i just had to make sure it was the right
one hold on all right let me actually
play for you
uh
there is a video component hold on hold
on all right
this really brings back memories for me
and uh
i just really think you're gonna like
this
this is your ship correct
oh yeah that's my ship it's my pride and
joy the invincible
i mean it's our ship actually this is
the captain so technically they are in
charge oh
you're in charge
so
this ship is your responsibility
i swear if one more thing blows up on my
ship i'm gonna lose it
warning large object on collision course
with shell
brace for
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered that there is
no right answer have we been here
before
everything has cost
has to be
[Music]
wow
yeah
april 4th
april 4th free
it's free
anyway
if you want to see that again maybe 99
more times the link to that is in the
description below and the show comes out
april 4th for free on my channel for
everyone to watch you will enjoy it
you will but because i'm not an [ __ ]
i see what you were trying to type and i
will auto correct it for you
thank you for selecting
exotic butters
[Music]
wait is this is this the right one i
can't remember
[Music]
there are many there are many i think
this is the one
it's been a while
[Music]
all right anyway i'll play all whole one
that's by cool songs uh way back in 2016
of all times i'm actually
out of time
and i know you guys are probably
yearning for the rest of uh sister
location but i have good news for you
that
game i played it way back in 2016 so i
have the full playthrough on my channel
if you want to see that but
i'm going however do remember
that in space with markiplier launches
april 4th
for free on my channel
i have a lot more work than i need to
take care of before the show comes out
but it is all going to be so fun
i can't wait for you to see it so
definitely be there on the day
lots of cool surprises
lots of fun
you're gonna love it
you're gonna love it and it's free
please spread the word about that like
there are so many people that
think that it costs money that you you
do not need a youtube premium
subscription you do not need anything
you just need to go to my channel and
you can watch it please help me spread
the word about that because people still
don't know
they assume
that it's it's a subscription thing
because so many things like this on the
internet are a subscription thing this
is not
this is a passion project
and it's something that i'm incredibly
proud of so i need your help in
spreading the word that it is in fact
free and you can confirm that because
heist was free you can go watch heist
right now if you want to see it i
recommend it if you haven't seen any of
my other stuff go watch that one
it's pretty cool anyway i gotta go thank
you
and as always
i'll see you when
april 4th
very soon two weeks all right